We're going to discuss a little bit about knots and links.
How about how to use coloring knots and links to study than me.
I'll take,
say a piece of string and I'll projected on a Blackboard or a piece of paper.
That's called a projection of a nod. And you see,
when I projected there are overs and unders that,
tell me how it looked when it was back in three dimensional space. Now,
of course you could think of a piece of string as just going like a line,
but in mathematics,
it's convenient to take the two ends of the string and connect them together.
So that forms a circle all the way around, right? If you don't stick,
the two ends together, you could, of course,
always a not something just by pulling the strand through.
And I'm trying to avoid doing that so that I can talk about when two knots are
different,
it looks like a circle in the sense that if I had a little ant sitting on this,
for example, here's my little land.
It would walk around this way and then they keep going and keep going and keep
going. And then he would come back.
Gradually he or she actually it's chief in case of ants would come back to where
she was at the very beginning. And that's what makes it a circle.
But it's a complicated circle in that. It's not just like this, right?
This would be what we call the trivial nod or the unknown,
which has no Noddings.
This is a not in the sense that you can't get from this picture to this picture
without doing something,
this continuous like cutting the nod or something like that in mathematics,
we're interested in studying classification of knots. How,
what can you say about nods? How many are there with S with a certain level of,
of Noddings and things like that?
How do you actually prove that these two knots are different?
It's not so obvious. In other words, you notice that when you're a kid,
for example, I love to do it.
When I was a kid you'd like taking some piece of string making it look like it's
really complicated, oddly nodded.
And then you fool the adults by showing that it just yanks out. Right?
So how do you know that isn't true of this or that you couldn't get from this to
this by doing something like making it much more complicated and then somehow
yanking it out. In fact, we can prove that there's no way to go from this,
to this beyond that. And this not, this thought is called the trefoil knot.
It's the first non-trivial knob.
And how do you prove that there's no way to go from this to this, right?
How do you know that if you did a zillion ways of moving it around,
the Noddings wouldn't come up.
So out, right? It's like just making it is not enough and like fiddling around.
Right? Right. You could say, why don't you just count the number of crossings,
right?
The trouble is you can change the number of crossings in various ways in a, not.
So this knot has three crossings where there's an over going on top of an under
there's one over here. There's another one over here.
And there's another one over here.
So there are three places where one strand lies on top of another like that.
So you could say, why don't you just count the number of crossings?
This one has zero crossings. This one has three crossings.
And it is true that the minimum number of crossings you need for this one is
three. And for this one, the number of crossings is zero.
But the trouble is that you can change the coursing numbers. For example,
a simple, dumb bunny way to change.
The crossing numbers is introduced into a piece of a, not a pig like that,
which obviously he could yank out, right?
There are three basic ways that you can introduce more crossings in an art.
Those are called the writer mice to moves. This is the first one,
the simplest one. And there are two more that involve more strands.
And the problem is that the right of mice to move seem to increase the number of
crossings, but you can do the opposite and decrease.
And so you haven't solved the problem of why can't you get rid of all the
crossings by doing a lot of these right of mice.
The moves may be first complicated and make a million crossings,
but then yank it out and get down to zero. So what I mean,
is that just like a cosmetic crossing or is it like a lifetime crossing?
Absolutely. That's the issue. Now, let me draw a few of the other rider, mice,
the moves,
and any motion of a knot can be broken up into a series of these simple
motions. So this is one, the pig tail would, you could yank out,
you could yak the pig tail out to just get a straight line, for example,
and the segment of the knot,
or you could have two segments of the knot that are, for example,
not doing anything at all, lying next to each other.
And then you pull one strand over the other ones.
So you would take this and you could move it so that it would look for example,
like this with one strand logoing over and the other one just going always
under. And obviously you could yank this back to look like that, right.
Or vice versa. So that's the right of my strategic.
And there's one more complicated motion to our three,
which involves three strands. And there, what you do is you have two strands.
One is crossing over the other and a third strand comes in and then
goes, let's say over both of them say like that. So this looks like this.
And then what I could do when I have three strands, for example,
I could move it to a picture where this guy that's going always over,
moves over, further up. Instead of down here,
he could move over here over all of them like that. Get what I mean.
And now obviously I could do that by just pulling the third strand higher.
So that's our three. So those are obvious,
simple moves that you can do and change the projection of a knot.
And now the question is,
how do you prove that there's no way to go from the trefoil dock to the I'm not
using these simple moves or to give another example.
There's a simple knot called the figure eight.
And you see it's going to have in the middle,
something that looks like a figure eight, roughly
This one has zero crossings. This one has three crossings.
This one let's count them as one.
Two, three.
For crossings. This is a for crossing that.
And one can prove that actually not only is there no way to go from this
one to the unknot, but also these are two different knots. In other words,
just by moving this around without cutting it,
there's no way to go from the trefoil to the figure eight or the figure eight to
the trefle. So the, here we have an example already right away of three,
really different knots. We can complicate them by doing these motions, right?
Or mice, the moves.
We could might try to simplify them by other right of mice to moves.
But in fact, matter how many zillions of moves we make?
These three are all different and there's no way to go from one to the other,
right?
As a professor, it feels like these ride a Meister moves.
They're like cosmetic moves.
That's right. They don't change the underlying type of the nod.
They changed the way it sits in three-dimensional space,
but they're equivalent to each other.
We as not in the sense that one can be deformed continuously to the other
without cutting it. There are tables of knots,
which tabulate knots by the minimum number of crossings. So this is the only,
not with zero crossings. This is the first non trivial,
not the one that's not the unknown is the trefle, Knotel three crossings.
This is the one with four crossings. There are two with five crossings.
And then the number of knots begins to go up very fast.
By the time you're up into say 12 crossing knots,
you've got tens of thousands of them. And so on
The question is how do you prove that they're different from each other? Now,
mathematicians have a whole bunch of different methods of doing that.
Using geometry, using algebra, using a bunch of different ideas,
but there's a very, pretty old idea that can be explained to, you know,
bright high school students by using coloring of knots.
And that's what I propose to show you because it's very visual and you can just
see it. So the idea is the following. I'm going to consider the problem problem.
And for simplicity, I'm just going to be working with three colors.
So what do I mean by three coloring?
I mean that when I take a projection of a knot like this picture over here,
I'm going to color each of the apparent segments that I see on the,
the projection. So for example, in this case, because I had four crossings,
they look like there are four segments over here where it's unbroken.
There's one here. And there's another one that goes all the way around here.
And another one here.
And so on four crossings gave me four segments that is broken up into,
and I'm going to try to color the, not using three different colors.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going to try coloring it in a way so that with
a certain rules about how I'm allowed to color it.
And then I'll see that with these rules,
some knots can be three colored and some knots cannot be three colored.
And that's going to let me distinguish one kind of,
not from another kind of not. So I'll be dividing the, the knots into two kinds.
Those which can be three colored and those which cannot be three colored. Now,
that's not a way of telling all knots apart,
cause it's kind of crude that I'm only dividing them up into two sets,
but still it'll tell me that some of them are not equal,
cannot be the form to the other ones.
Now I have to have a rule because if I have no rule,
anything could be colored with three colors and then I'm not gaining any
information. So I have to have a rule,
but I want to have a rule that's compatible with my right or my S the moves in
the sense that if I could call her a not before,
there's an obvious way to then color it. After I do one of these right or mice,
the moves. So when I get to a crossing, there's an over one.
And then there are two unders one coming in the other side, one at a crossing.
I will see three colors because I will have the color of the over.
And then the two wonders coming there.
So I have to have three different colors here,
and I have to have some rule limiting what happens at a crossing.
One obvious rule to try to use is say, well,
since I'm trying to do this with three colors and at a crossing,
there are three strands coming together. The two wonders and the over,
maybe the rules should just be at a crossing point like this,
you get all three different colors.
That seems like the obvious rule to try insist that at a crossing,
it looks something like blue over here,
red over here and say green.
And I do those three colors together.
And that would be the rule to have that's a natural first guess it almost works,
but not quite being the reason that doesn't quite work.
You can see already because I has to be compatible with these rider mice,
the moves that as I do the right of mice, the moves,
the coloration or the color ability is maintained as I do them. Now,
if I do, for example, even just the pigtail.
So I start off with a single strand like that, and then I take the strand.
So this is somewhere in a big knock diagram, somewhere in it.
And I take this pigtail and that,
of course I can yank out and go back to what I had before.
So I can go back and forth between these two.
But notice what happens that at the crossing I'm coming in from somewhere other
stuff and the not. So I'm becoming in blue and I'm going out blue. Well,
that's it. Then I've gotta be blue all the way.
So you can see that at this crossing that I've introduced with the pig tail in
order to make it compatible with what I had before, I have no choice,
but to allow it to crossing all three colors, to be the same at that crossing.
So I'm going to modify my first guests for the possibility that all three are
the same,
how tentative new rule is going to be all three different or all
three the same. Okay. And that's a rule which we can check now,
case by case is compatible with these right or mice, the moves.
And now I do the second rider, my second rule, and the second rider,
nicely move consisted of pulling one of these over the other I'm coming in from
elsewhere in the knots. So I can't change the ends of this. So I've,
I'm now I'm going to have a, one of this is coming in blue.
The other one is still coming in red also. And in fact,
they've got to go out the same way,
the fit with what's going on elsewhere in the not. So here,
this is going to go out red,
and this is still going to go out blue like it did before over here.
But what happens in between, well,
in between this red guy goes over here and comes over in this right.
Or mice that move here and then goes back here and connects up here. Fine.
This one is going to continue all the way down. And then of course,
that's something I could yank out by the second, right.
Or mice to move just by pulling this back over there.
And then I would get my original picture, but see what happens.
Remember my rule was that, of course, all three are different,
rural three of the same. So at this crossing I have here blue and red.
So now I've got to get green coming out of there.
I have green coming out of there coming down here and here's green. Ah,
and now I'm in luck because there's green and red and blue coming together.
And that's compatible yeah. With my rule, because at that crossing,
all three are different.
So we see that this rule is compatible with the first right of mice to move
the second right of mice to move. And in fact,
we could check more cases to see that it's compatible the third one.
So this property of being colorable with this rule stays the same as I do
all three of the writer, Meister moves with me.
And now I want to have another trivial coloring by non-trivial coloring. I mean,
with more than one color.
So the question I'm going to ask myself is which knots have a CRE coloring with
this rule with more than one color. Of course, every not has the silly color,
the trivial coloring, right color it all one color. So that's not of interest,
but I want to do it with more than one color. Okay.
And now you'll notice that this one, the unknot does,
I can only call it a one color because there were no crossings.
So this does not have a non-trivial coloring. This has only a silly coloring.
And as I move it around,
that's where I'm going to keep getting is that silly coloring.
And I'm not going to be able to color it with different colors,
no matter how I move it, I will not be able to color it. Non trivially, uh,
subject to this rule. Let's look at the Treflan C is the trefoil colorable.
Well, okay. So for example, this strand over here is going to be red.
Then there's going to be another strand, which is going to be blue.
Let's say this one, look, and then there's going to be a strand.
That's going to be green. Let's say this one. And now lo and behold,
you'll notice that at each of the crossings, we have all three colors.
So this Treflan not.
Haha great success is in fact three colorable.
This is an example of a three colorable not,
and this one is not three colorable.
And the last one we're going to consider today is the figure. Eight,
not suppose that this trend was red. And then this strand let's say was green.
Let's say, well, if this strand is red and this one is green, then this one,
because it's the third one where they meet here would have to be blue.
So this one would be blue over here. Well,
if this one is blue and this one is red,
then this one over here also has to be green because these three are me meeting
at them pointed. That was our coloring rule.
That they either have to be all three different or the same.
But if this one is green and this one is green,
then these two greens meet at this point.
So the third one would have to be the same color.
Remember all three different rural three, the same.
So we'd have to have green here, but that contradicts that this guy was red.
So we see that this one is not three colorable by this simple technique of
studying three color ability.
We have proved that the trefoil and the figure eight knot are not the same
because one of them is three colorable. One of them is not three colorable.
What we haven't succeeded at proving is we haven't yet proved that the figure
eight knot doesn't or not,
because all we know about the figure eight knot is that it's not three
colorable. And that happened also to be true about the trivial nod.
So we haven't yet proved that these two guys are different.
We've proven that they're all different from the trefoil,
but we haven't yet succeeded at showing,
but I could generalize this trick on a little,
slightly more elaborate way for say five colors. And if I use five colors,
this one will turn out to be not five colorable and this one would turn out.
It is five colorable.
And so the upshot would be that these two are in fact different.
So by doing three color ability and handing on a further level of study to this,
the five color Bailey,
I would indeed have succeeded at proving that all three of these are different
knots in particular.
There's no way to are not the truffle or the figure eight knot by without
cutting it. And also there's no way to move. As we saw already the three,
the trefoil into the figure eight,
they can't get from one to the other just by continuous motions.
Quite good for elementary, just coloring around. Don't you think.
Just because this one is three colorable and that one's, I mean, that does seem.
Tolerable because the point is that after I fill in the steps that I skipped
over, right, or which I took an example of, but didn't do the others of that.
The point is that if a nod is three colorable,
as I do these rider buys the moves and move it around and change the number of
crossings,
the property of three color ability is maintained all the way through.
For example, when I did the pig tail and I put in a pig tail,
it was compatible. In fact, I adapted the rules.
So as to achieve this property and modified by original guests.
And so if this is three colorable, as I move it around continuously,
without coloring, without cutting it, though,
I changed the number of crossings and may make it like the Kitty's thing.
Fantastically, more complicated looking before I try to simplify it.
Nevertheless, at the very end three color ability,
if it was three combos at the beginning, it will be three colorable VN.
If it was not three colorable at the beginning,
it will not be three collarbone VN.
And so the fact that the one is recallable and the other is not three colorable
with the given projection means that there's no way to move this
And understand culpability better by developing the theory of polynomial and
variance of knots. Specifically,
there's an old polynomial invariant that goes back about a hundred years,
the polynomial and variant for this not turns out to be Delta vex.
The PA the Alexander polynomial is X squared minus X plus one.